trump says don't be afraid the media say
do be afraid
jake tapper on cnn i think he typified
his entire profession
when he watched that scene of president
trump when he listened to him say do not
be afraid
and he couldn't have been angrier
president trump wrote
on twitter don't be afraid of kovit
don't let it dominate your life
almost 210 000 americans are
dead from this disease meaning hundreds
of thousands of people
in this country are mourning or we just
reached
we look at that we just reached 210 000
uh since i've been on air
210 000 americans dead hundreds of
thousands if not millions of americans
mourning them
7.4 million americans have contracted
the disease many of them are going to
have health problems for the rest of
their life
for president trump who gets the best
medical care of anybody in the world to
say
don't be afraid of kova don't let it
dominate your life there are
children who don't have parents now
because of this virus
don't let it dominate your life i mean
jake this is this is so disrespectful
i'm not even sure i can i can speak
about this in some sort of
uh cogent way here it is disrespectful
this segment on jake tapper's show is
very
very very disrespectful nothing trump
said is disrespectful
it's it's amazing if president trump
were a democrat and he gave this speech
they'd be hailing it as the greatest
speech since fdr said
that there is nothing to fear but fear
itself should fdr not have said that fdr
should have come out and said
in the depths of the depression there is
a lot to fear you got to be afraid
man people are losing their whole
livelihoods people are killing
themselves
children don't have parents now be
afraid be very very afraid
that's what the media want to tell you
how ghoulish is it that cnn has a clock
of people who die
from coronavirus did you see jake tapper
there that hack
did you see what he said sitting there
the president is
he's recovered and he's strong and but
people are dying oh look haha look yes
210 000 people now yes
be afraid don't look so happy jake don't
look so happy
i was speaking yesterday when i was
hosting ben's show to dr marty mccary
i said what are we going to make of this
in light of other epidemics and he said
well it's very selective how the
mainstream media are talking about this
because of course what was it just a few
years ago we had almost 80 000 deaths
from the seasonal flu
should the president come out and say be
afraid of the flu be very afraid stay at
home because of the flu
children don't have parents because of
the flu of course that's true
should we should we fearmonger over that
no
no you cannot live in fear what the
media are trying to say that trump said
is that
the disease poses no danger at all that
isn't what he said
that isn't what we conservatives are
saying either i made this point
yesterday we're not saying don't be
afraid
because the virus can't infect you or
because there won't be negative
consequences from the virus
we're saying don't be afraid because we
have to live
our lives this get does get i suppose
to a bottom religious difference which
is that
if you are a christian at least a
christian i suppose if you're
religious in other ways as well or
you're an adherent to other religions
too
you'd often you don't believe that this
is
all there is i'm not no expert on
judaism in islam but i think that they
have views
that are a little bit bigger than this
material world certainly christians do
this isn't the end of the story there
are more important things
to life than than just our physical
selves
okay there are more important by the way
even if you're just a
total stone cold atheist let's say
you're just a stoic
let's say that you you're not focused on
the
the life after death still
you can have courage still you can say
i'm being confronted with this challenge
and i'm gonna face it head on like a man
with toughness we used to say that in
this country
and then the whiny sniveling mainstream
media
come out and tell us to be afraid how
dare they how dare they do that it's a
horrible thing to do
terrible way to tell people to live
their lives
and by the way jake tapper wasn't
incredibly the most hysterical person on
this yesterday
that honor went to the cbs a white house
correspondent
who wished that he were in north korea
because he would feel safer
you know safety at the white house
compared to other places around the
world
is i think a little bit higher for most
journalists i think a lot of journalists
when they go north korea or other
tyrannical regimes
they're in much greater danger
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you